e aí galera que aceite meu canal todo
bom você como encarar tudo ótimo né
tinha esse dia eu fui muito que eu em
casa não me dá uma saudade muito grande
a minha mãe está lembrando de quando eu
era criança que a mãe da gente ela faz
uma coisa estranha não sei o que é não
gastei um um ditado estranho pois é
quando ele era criança ela batia na
gente é de chorar um pouquinho a a
alegria do choro no chão e não chove
amanhã não é carla bock foi quando quer
vertical quem foi ontem não é da
propaganda enganosa dizem querer enganá
la boca modesta ficar calado
quem foi que mandou quebrar esse copo
aqui eu estou falando com quem
num pódio quando eu falar que você pode
ou não fosse ela eu queria ficar calado
andava lá manhã o inter era pra ficar
calado era pra falar essa confusão que
ele não sabia se era pra falar pra ficar
calado a gente já estava nervosa ela
agradecia água por aqui por aqui pela
testa pela areia eo catar o bc e no pay
porque eu era pobre a emoção do choro do
filho do pobre é o catarro gente pode
ver que o choro da criança do pop quando
vencem catava eu pensei em emoção eo
choro de uma criança de pobre ela só tem
graça se ela tiver emoção tanto que
minha mãe me batia quando eu chorava ela
tinha que me bater e até o carro sair
que outras porque não entende a minha
mãe que quando estar desesperado e chora
não é dizer sim é igual em f choro
engole o show eu não sabia como é que
nenhum show ea gente com o diabo que
engole um shuttle run manhã foi ou não
mas também toda coisa me engole s show
eu ficava doido querem saber como é que
incluiu fã
hum eu ficar doida eu não sabia como já
que engolir um show mais agora que eu -
entendia com a minha mãe falava o
seguinte às vezes atacou muito ocupada
foi plantada lavando roupa eu dar um
fumo né eu ia pedir comida pra ela que é
isso que a criança faz a mãe tem que ter
um ano e como ela vai pedir alimento na
hora que ela quer e aí eu ia até ela
chegar mãe eu tô com fome a dizer assim
vai cagar do paraíba eu fiquei indignado
fico eu te dizer mãe pela mãe de 11 anos
engoliu shows acho que ser carregado com
o pahi mamãe ou boca não entendiam nunca
entendia quando a mãe fazia o seguinte a
criança não é burro vocês a criança é
bom ela não perde a mãe passar ela não
chega simões deixou sair que ela faz ela
se a manter produtores inter se perfuma
chega na mãe bem bonitinha de mãe é mãe
vejo sair amanhã a gente diz não o manhã
r10 chão eu adoro tudo que eu não vou
sair mãe no beijo o que mais nos deixa
sair porque não o moisés desceu o irmão
royce o não vai e não vai porque não mas
pelo amor de deus mas o de juntar um
mesmo a minha filha meu prometo
eu prometo a senhora que eu nunca mais
alma esse ano eu falei que não ele
a oms não é difícil aquela canção tá bom
tá bom tá bom é de corpos guardei passa
meia hora chora a mãe da gente espera
meia hora
chorando na porta do quarto
o índice
o edson e foi mais vaga fica com a festa
vai pro am
mães do brasil o que você espera gente
chorar achando que nosso sonho de sair
morreu a dizer que pode gente não faça
isso não faça em não faça isso nem
sequer o pior quando a gente pede pra
vocês passarem você diria que impeça o
seu pai
a gente chega pai mãe disse que o pedido
se eu passaria de espécie para sua mãe
a gente chega na mãe mãe ou o pai disse
que eu pedi pro céu e vi espécie de seu
pai parece que os dois a cada um toque
toque do lacen vai agora a mãe dele pra
mim chega na mãe pede espécie seu pai na
hora que a gente saiba falar olha
maneira o pacote vai mandar lhe pediu
para pedir pra mim de novo aí foi um
parceiro parece um complô contra mim que
sou muito fã do morro
nunca na minha filha uma vez que aquela
casca de melancia na cabeça da senhora
mas foi sem querer no formato que o fã
homicídio culposo e ela nem morreu
favoreceu não bastasse passar a infância
todinha brigando agora elas estão
entrando a esap você não tem idéia do
tanto de fernandão que o que eu recebo
em áudio e minha mãe é o seguinte ela
vai mandar organizar pra mim ela acha
que está cobrando pênalti amanhã à noite
pelo amor de deus meu filho você tá
parecendo que eu falei pra você falar
comigo não pode vir no meu programa na
gala um bom papo alegre por ter tomado
do livro de café com red bull o texto
que ela tinha pra falar pra mim presença
quando era criança ela manda em 20
segundo a psa ou seja quando ela manda o
molde do minuto é que fugiu muito se
você ama sua mãe que gostei desse vídeo
se você não ama só lhe ia aproveitar e
mandar um abraço e um beijo pra minha
mãe que estou com muita saudade meu deus
ou a saudade daquela velha chata que
mandar um abraço também a todas as mães
de vocês que estão assistindo que muitas
vezes um presente na maioria dos shows
muito obrigado vocês assistir esse vídeo
você e sua mãe
muito obrigado se você tiver curtir esse
vídeo clipe gostei aqui não se esquece
de volta lá no facebook apostar nesse
vídeo e curtir a postagem do vídeo
aproveita e marca seus amigos lá na
postagem do facebook beleza viu isso
aqui no twitter vou falar no twitter e
dar rt que me ajuda demais
escreve o canal para não perder o vídeo
levando a galera do rio de janeiro que
amanhã eu tô em amanhã dia 25 de julho
sábado e voltar no rio de janeiro no
teatro odylo costa filho às quatro horas
da tarde e sabe que pra mim que estou
começando a maratona de show é muito
difícil de ser nessa parte do mapa que é
um pouco difícil então espero que todos
os meus bichos outro lado do rio de
janeiro comparecer ao show tá muito
obrigado a todo mundo que assistiu vir
até aqui e na excelente pé